joining me today is an evolutionary
psychologist and author and associate
professor at the University of New
Mexico Jeffrey Miller welcome to the
Rubin report Dave great to be here good
to be with you my friend
you know I realized I've had
evolutionary biologists on the show I've
had Brett Weinstein and Richard Dawkins
I've had psychologists on the show
Jordan Peterson I've never had an
evolutionary psychologist never know
very many of us yeah how many how many
are there we're almost extinct yeah the
big international conference we get
maybe 300 people versus like a big
neuroscience conference we'll be 30,000
that's got to be a tough crowd it's a
tough crowd
we get a lot of flack from all
directions but I would I wouldn't want
to do anything else it's an it's an
awesome field and I can't imagine
anything more fun than studying human
nature for a living yeah and you're
studying and have written about so many
incredible topics I normally I always I
pride myself on the fact that I usually
don't have to look at my notes when
interviewing somebody but you've been so
many things that every now and again I
am gonna be glancing down because I
don't want to miss anything here but
usually the way I like to start these is
just finding out a little bit of
someone's history what sort of brought
them to the place of expertise that gets
them in that chair so just tell me a
little bit about you know growing up
education that sort of thing what made
you interested in all this I was born
and raised in Cincinnati Ohio went to
undergrad at Columbia University I
studied psychology and biology and just
anything that grabbed my interest so I
kind of started out in neuroscience and
I thought the brain's fascinating and
then I kind of drifted into cognitive
psychology which is studying human
learning and memory and perception and
how we categorize stuff and then I got
really bored with that but I thought I
don't I don't know a go a go pH do a PhD
in that anyway so I went to Stanford
started doing cognitive psychology but
when I was there I met these two
brilliant postdocs who are working with
my adviser leda cosmides and john tooby
who had just come from
Harvard and they basically invented the
field of evolutionary psychology right
there at Stanford in front of my nose
hmm from the ground up
and they were like we're going to take
evolutionary biology anthropology
cognitive psychology merge them all
together and make this new science of
human nature
yeah so let's slow down for a second so
how what does that synthesis look like
what does that even mean when they're
yeah talking about this how do you take
these things that are thought of as
their own institutions and you know put
them into one box it's basically like
the key insight is if you want to
understand human nature whether it's
anything human sexuality or emotions or
how we relate to other people or other
groups you could always ask the question
where did we come from
what challenges that our ancestors faced
in terms of surviving and reproducing
and raising kids and what exact
structure did those challenges have like
what was ancestral life like we don't
know every every detail but we do know a
lot from anthropologists who studied
hunter-gatherers we know a lot from
primatologists who have studied chimps
and bonobos and and and gorillas and the
rank towns and you can kind of
triangulate on a picture of prehistoric
life and figure out yeah like why do we
fear certain things snakes and spiders
and bears and whatever well it's because
there were certain selection pressures
like if you don't fear those things you
die why do we look for certain things in
mates when we're choosing sexual
partners well if you don't look for
those things then you have bad
relationships and bad kids etc so it's a
way of looking at the past to inform our
understanding of the present and that's
not what most of psychology does so it's
quite a novel kind of approach but I
think we've got we've got an enormous
leverage out of it was there pushback
from people within each discipline going
well we've got all the answers right
here why do we want to put these things
together because I would imagine there's
always a certainty inherently
competition amongst all of these
different disciplines
yeah the evolutionary biologists kind of
hate it because
to be my next question since I know
they're a couple of those guys they're
happy to go here's how other animals
evolve they're happy to go here's how
the human body evolved here's how the
human immune system evolved but once you
get above the neck then they're like
you're just gonna make trouble for us
and biology because that's where things
get politically controversial is when
you start explaining human behavior or
individual differences or sex
differences or human emotions with stuff
like that so the biologists don't like
it the anthropologists had a lot of the
same issues like we've spent the last
century trying to get anthropology kind
of a way from biology in a way so please
don't drag us kicking and screaming back
into that yeah that swamp of controversy
but we just got kind of plowed ahead and
and I think it's been a big success
story and in the sciences in the last 30
years so what were the things that were
intriguing to you that had sort of bored
you from the other I think the the fact
that sexuality is central to
evolutionary biology and evolutionary
psychology you know it's how how we got
our genes and the next generation is
choosing mates and having babies and
raising raising kids and if you ignore
that you ignore I think one of the core
driving forces in human nature and human
culture now most of psychology kind of
ignores mate choice and sexuality and
reproduction except insofar as it's kind
of like seen as politically relevant so
like you'll get a little bit on well
there's sexual discrimination against
certain kind of groups which is
important to address like gay and
lesbian rights and and so forth but they
don't really see it as central to who we
are into what motivates us so do you see
it as the real pillar of what's
motivating us like if we were sort of
looking at this in action
circles I think it depends where you're
at in life I think for young single
people what we call mating effort like
the attempt to attract other people
whatever is such orientation that drives
an awful lot of behavior how you dress
what ideas you adopt why you bother to
learn things why you bother to get
credentials I think a lot of that is
driven by mating effort but then if you
settle down and you're in a long-term
monogamous relationship you don't kind
of need to do that stuff but that's
exactly what really though that's where
people let themselves go right they
don't stay in shape they dress more
sloppily they kind of don't bother
reading like serious nonfiction anymore
why because a lot of that sort of
creative display has already
accomplished its its purpose so in that
way that's not in real conflict with
evolutionary biology right because you
want to look your best to get the best
media that's what in that way you guys
are on the same track so where does that
where does that deviate well so when
biologists talk about courtship displays
and here's the bowerbird building its
power and we talked about like
ideological displays and there's people
showing off like their virtues for
virtue signaling the biologists know
exactly what we're talking about and we
know exactly what they're talking about
it's just often they don't want to get
in the trouble that that follows if they
kind of make these analogies too clearly
have you had any of these conversations
with Brett Weinstein not directly yeah
no I think I'm gonna have to facilitate
that one probably those or there'll be a
lot of fun yeah yeah I'll do that for
sure
so it's interesting okay so let's let's
focus on the sexuality parties for a
little bit because it seems like so many
things that we used to be able to talk
about we suddenly can't talk about or
that academics are self-selecting out of
and things of that nature now I said to
you right before we started you're one
of the few people I see our Twitter I'm
like oh you guys guess what Twitter is
because you put on some smart stuff
you're kind of funny on there at the
right time you know when to go with
snark and all of those things
and that to me seems the only way that
you would be able to have any of these
conversations online I think social
media is actually really good for
addressing some of these very tricky
issues like human sexuality and how it's
playing out in the modern world as long
as you do with humor and self
deprecation and a little bit of
absurdity which is what I try to do in
my Twitter game right because if you
approach it like well here's the next
paper on like sex differences or the
next paper on how courtship works or Oh
awesome a new virtue signaling paper
people will quickly tune out and the
lost and often think well you're just
kind of being doctrinaire here but the
thing you quickly realize if you study
evolution at all is evolution is a very
weird process that often produces
completely absurd results right you
watch any David Attenborough Natural
History
you know documentary and it's like these
animals are insane what they're doing is
crazy and humans are no different yeah
and if you don't have a sense of that
absurdity then it's very easy to get
terribly terribly serious and censorious
and ideological and that really
catalyzed a lot doesn't is going on that
doesn't really help anybody yeah all
right so let's let's pause on sexuality
for a second I don't want to get off
that topic so to speak but let's just do
the 2-minute Twitter portion of the show
which is is there a evolutionary
explanation to the way we're behaving
with each other is there a psychological
explanation to the way we act one way on
this medium and another way on another
medium and and how that has evolved
because of the age of communication it's
a great question and I think honestly
social media blindsided everybody I
don't know anybody in the 90s in
psychology or any behavioral science who
was going here's what the Internet is
going to turn into right it'll become
this massive global system of very rapid
fire interact
snarky virtue signaling that drives
everyone nuts and yet we can't give it
up yeah I know villain k dick probably
would not but maybe nobody else yeah
okay dick maybe William Gibson a few
other folks kind of add the insight but
honestly nobody was deriving kind of
from first principles well we are a
social primate and we love to gossip and
we love to show off you know our virtues
and our intelligence to each other and
therefore obviously there will be this
thing called Facebook and Twitter and
whatever and it will play out in this
way and moreover it will revolutionize
politics or culture in some way
no nobody thought that so we can come up
with post hoc reasons why that might
have played out that way but I want to
only do that with a very high degree of
humility like I don't know I don't it
now that we're here you can kind of a
little bit make sense of it that well
it's almost like you can see the
evolution um Twitter you know domain
where you now see people I'd like to
include myself of that where they're
trying to clean it up a little bit it's
like we all did this unknown thing of
snark that everyone was trying to
destroy each other and one-up each other
and you signal about the things we care
about all that
and it's like now I'm seeing a growing
group of people that are like whoa how
do we deal with reality in the confines
of social media but little maturely and
honestly and without just wrecking
everything and that almost strikes me as
an evolutionary function and it's
evolution is happening so fast and on
such a huge scale I mean who could have
predicted that like the more amateurish
looking a visual mean is a better it
would spread that's completely bizarre
or the fact that I can get more
engagement if I do a really surreal poll
on Twitter about something where all
four categories are just completely
insane
like people are more into that right
than they are like even my snarky
comment about political issue X or Y so
what does that tell you about the
psychological state of how we interact
with these things like the mean one's
really interesting it's not the slate I
produced quick thing you know really
sharp looking images that go viral it's
you know a frog on a black-and-white
idiotic thing or a crudely drawn this or
that tree or whatever like there's
something really there today about how
we react to images this there's also
something kind of charming about the
artlessness and amateurish quality it's
almost like if I'm kind of fascinated by
stand-up comedy and the stand-up
comedians who are overly slick are never
that funny and the ones who are a little
bit shambolic like stephen wright back
in the 80s hilarious and he looks he
looks like he's always on the edge of
complete failure or a psychotic break
and yet that's what makes it work or I
guess Seinfeld's you know in the 90s the
show was also kind of had this art less
quality yeah alright so let's do that so
that's already now okay it's getting
harder and harder to talk about these
things there's a set of people that
think we're all exactly the same and
then at the same time they're obsessed
with all of our differences I mean this
is what seemingly is the most potent
idea of the day right now what are what
are the things that you're thinking
about in the realm of sexuality right
now that are intriguing I'm thinking I'm
especially concerned about the fact that
nobody seems to know what a successful
long-term relationship is seriously
going to look like in the early to mid
21st century that we don't really have a
script for that we've kind of inherited
you know the script of monogamous
lifelong marriage but nobody really
believes that that is going to kind of
solve all of our problems and people
don't enter into that very early in life
they spend their teens and 20s doing
casual dating what is that like nobody
quite understands what the
the rules where the ethics of that are
and that at a certain point you kind of
get tired of that and you find a partner
and you kind of settle down and go okay
we're going to buy into the wedding
industry now and do the wedding thing
and the ring bottle but they're all
these subcultures in America and around
the world that are exploring all
different aspects sexuality and kind of
how to incorporate new insights into
relationships things like BDSM or kink
or polyamory and open relationships or
the whole red pill manosphere subculture
and then on the other side of those what
does that have to do with sexuality well
it's a certain way of men and women
interacting right the sort of red pill
vision of male-female dynamics is that
there's a really deep sexual polarity
masculine and feminine and if you don't
understand that polarity your
relationships if they're heterosexual
are gonna fail and burn out and not be
satisfying to either person so there's
much subcultures they're all exploring
different parts of human nature human
sexuality different possible ways to run
a relationship and I think they all have
valuable lessons that we can kind of
learn and incorporate like even if
you're vanilla and monogamous and
straight and you you don't believe all
the the crazy manosphere stuff there's
still important lessons there and that's
kind of my interest now is sort of going
around and and being eclectic and
gathering those up and figuring out
which of those might be useful do people
stay in those scenes for a lifetime so I
you know I could see worse where
somebody you'd be in a whatever your
thing is I'm not passing judgment on
anything whatever your thing is you do
it for awhile and then eventually I
guess it sort of is the men you sort of
get tired of it so you move on to
something more traditionally is that
just part of our psychology like nothing
kind of lasts forever some people do
that certainly there's
there's a life profile a kind of
openness and experimentation where you
you try a bunch of stuff in your teens
and 20s and a lot of it deviates
markedly from the traditional culture
you you grow up in and a lot of that
hurts and it doesn't work and it's
heartbreaking and then you a lot of
people kind of drift back into the
mainstream on the other hand you got
people who marry young and they try the
the standard vanilla monogamy thing into
their 30s 40s 50s and then go this is
not working I need something different
better more open whatever and I think it
can go either way
you know the psychological research on
all these subcultures is lacking we
don't know even which lasts longer a
monogamous relationship or an open
relationship everybody don't we don't we
don't know there's not good data on that
there's lots of anecdotes there's
examples on both sides but I think it's
almost scientific misconduct not to ask
those questions and instead to ask like
let's do you know study on which
alcoholism treatment works let's do the
5,000th study on that before we do the
first study on what kind of
relationships last longest so basically
because you think if we could address
some of those issues first
perhaps the studies that we're focusing
on related to out as well Elizabeth yeah
relationship satisfaction is really
really important to people but it's one
of the the things that's it's not
entirely taboo to study it but it's
pretty hard to get federal research
funding to look at something that's kind
of a cornerstone of American well-being
so when that New York Times article came
out about Jordan Peterson and they said
he was for enforced monogamy mmm-hmm
which in effect just means marriage and
if you used a couple times in the times
before it just to me marriage but yeah
when everyone thought that man he wanted
me in Chains to be you know dragged
around by their husbands the the
argument that people that are for
forced monogamy your marriage basically
make is that this is the best way to
build a sort of functioning healthy
society and that you can reproduce and
have other generations and all of those
things you just think we don't have
enough information basically or enough
right well enough study on the
information to know if that really is
the best way to build a human society
right we don't know if there's there's
good reasons to think that monogamous
marriage has been important in every
major civilization like it's kind of the
most common way to arrange pair bonding
and I'm sure
Jordan Peterson has read the same
articles I've assigned even in my
polyamory class that's about here are
the benefits of monogamous marriage and
there are many benefits of it
the question is once you have
contraception once you have safer sex
and STI testing once you have paternity
testing once you have a lot of other
technologies right they can solve some
of the same issues that monogamy used to
solve then what is monogamy still
optimal probably is for a lot of people
probably as for love you how much of it
do you think just comes down to how
you're wired I think there's a lot of
that some people are just wired to go
and I just want to pair bond
I want my mate and I want to keep it
simple and that's good enough for me and
I will get a lot of companion at love
and attachment and it'll last a long
time a lot of people are very happy with
that and that's great but a lot of
people either want more sexual novelty
and variety or they have a higher
tolerance for sexual jealousy or they
just kind of get bored in long-term
relationships and I think those people
should not be prescribing like rampant
polyamory for the monogamists but the
monogamous shouldn't necessarily be
prescribing like our way is only way for
everybody else so I wonder how this is
all related to the gay community because
I don't know dare I mentioned the name
Milo but when
Mylo on my show years ago really before
he was Milan so to speak
we got it we had about a half-hour chat
on this where me is the married gay
liberal and him as the unmarried gay
conservative he's already sort of a flip
on things yeah
his argument was that he wasn't really
for gay marriage because he felt that by
being the outsider the gays have come up
with art and creativity and music and
comedy and all of those that incredible
like just Gestalt of it all that made
this incredible community like a diverse
community in the right sense of
diversity yeah and my argument was well
you've got to at least give people the
opportunity to be equal under the law so
that they at least have a choice I'm not
denying that the gay community has come
up with all sorts of incredible stuff
yeah but like you got to make them equal
and then let them go either way on that
okay yeah do you think there is
legitimacy to that and do you have you
done or have you seen any Studies on
what the effects of the marriage on the
gay community have been I haven't seen a
whole lot but I guess Miley too soon I
mean my understanding and some of this
comes from dan dan Savage right is that
a lot of gay couples have a kind of
monogamous relationship where it's like
we're pair bonded we love each other but
there's also a negotiated agreement that
we can have outside lovers once in a
while under certain conditions that we
kind of mutually agree to see it's funny
I hear that all the time I don't know
advocating couples that I know that are
married or you know really yeah together
I don't know ones that are like that or
at least that I know that they are like
okay but I know that this is a something
that's tossed out there yeah so we can
go with this Bert so but I'm sure
there's variety and I'm sure that
there's also kind of social assortment
all right
so that the more monogamist gay lesbian
couples will kind of be more comfortable
with each other and they might know
those crazy monogamous folks down the
road right or you just out of your
friends that well I mean yeah and
honestly it's not that different from
like the way you
and heterosexual relationships work in a
lot of Europe were a lot of those who
tacitly monogamish and there's a sort of
understanding that monogamy doesn't
necessarily mean sexual exclusivity for
either partner America is extremely
puritanical and kind of rigid about that
and we think anything that happens
outside the pair-bond is almost by
definition unethical and there is
research on a sort of anti polyamory
stigma where people actually are more
prejudiced against people in open
relationships than they are against
almost any other group in terms of
orientation or race or religion or
anything that might be gradually
changing but I think it's a it's a huge
social problem especially among Gen Z
and younger Millennials yeah where does
the trans part of this all fit in
because I remember years ago when people
would say when I when everyone started
saying the LGBT community I remember
thinking I have no more insight into the
T part of this then a straight cisgender
heterosexual male would you know and I
just I don't I maybe I have somehow
slightly a little more inherent empathy
by being an outsider at some level but I
don't have anymore knowledge of it and
now it seems like the trans issue has
almost superseded all of the other
issues at least in the last year I mean
everywhere yeah everywhere you go
there's you know every time I open the
Twitter search bar it's another trans
story or someone's being fired for this
joke or that what do you think happened
there that catapulted this so quickly
and what are the issues around it that
we're kind of afraid to talk about right
now it's a really complicated fraught
topic well I think Ryan gay I think like
the legitimate issue about trans is
there are people who are trans or feel
trans and they want their rights
respected and that's totally legitimate
and and good for them
and raising awareness about that is fine
there's a much larger group of people
who I think are using trans issues as a
kind of wedge to destroy the gender
binary or to kind of muddy the waters or
basically as a weapon to beat up
evolutionary psychology or evolutionary
biology to say there's no such thing as
sex really there's no such thing as
biological sex or sex is totally
dissociated from gender it says when
someone says that the next time someone
says that on Twitter what's the answer
that that the person watching this
should give that maybe Twitter's not the
best word for it
I mean male and female or evolved
strategies that exist because over
thousands of generations they were like
the paths to successful reproduction if
you're not clearly male and functioning
as a male or you're not clearly female
and functioning as a female you're your
genetic dead end so selection hammers
against any ambiguity there so it's not
surprising that the vast majority of
humans alive today clearly identify as
one sex or the other it doesn't mean
everyone should it doesn't have any kind
of moral implications about that but
just descriptively it means there is a
gender binary and it evolved for good
reasons and everyone who teaches biology
hopefully knows this and it shouldn't be
that or controversial right now if we
want to like genetically engineer people
and use CRISPR and whatever to destroy
the gender binary for the 22nd and 23rd
centuries we could do that we could talk
about that I don't have any particular
attachment to the kind of male-female
dichotomy ethically but I think
descriptively it's really important to
kind of accept it and and to go it it's
here it's valuable to understand and we
shouldn't necessarily try to
pretend it out of existence or pretend
that we're doing it in the name of trans
rights right you can have trans rights
without saying there's no such thing as
sex so this gets to the heart of what I
think is really happening in this
country right now which is everything
has become politicized to the point that
the experts in the field seem afraid to
talk about the issues you right now are
taking a risk by talking about these
issues yeah are you seeing this across
the board are you seeing this amongst
colleagues of fear to talk about these
things yeah absolutely
now the vast majority of people like in
my university don't really touch upon
anything that's particularly politicized
right they're just teaching civil
engineering or law or immunology or
whatever and most of that isn't really
politicized yet however yeah is the key
word yeah right right okay I mean you
get a little bit bit about what's the
gender representation in certain fields
but in my department in psychology you
do get almost everything having a kind
of political edge and I have colleagues
who are frightened to teach certain
classes like I teach psychology of human
sexuality and I'm pretty upfront
outspoken about what I cover and and
what my view is but a lot of my
colleagues will not touch it with a
barge pole because there's so much risk
that students will just get upset about
one little thing you say yeah and
complain to a Dean and then you'll get
called into the office and so what would
be that type of thing beyond what you
just said about the young and the
evidence of gender differences what what
are the other type of things that just
talking about are scaring the academics
it's very awkward to talk about sex
differences in any mental traits or
motivations or preferences it's hard to
talk about sexual coercion rape rape
harassment stalking etc that ones being
incredibly too
yeah yeah it's hard to talk about
aggression in general either between
individuals or between groups and how
that relates to sexuality like why
hunter-gatherer tribes go to war right
it's not typically about land or food
it's about women mm-hmm and that doesn't
fit the kind of Marxist picture of
prehistoric warfare right and then if
you talk about stuff like um pregnancy
child care parenting are you being you
know overly pronatalist and sort of
Family Values for talking about that
stuff is that alienating to certain
students who might be homosexual or
infertile or
adopted kids or whatever but it's so
interesting because I obviously hear
these types of stories from academics
all the time not only in here but but
online and people email me all the time
and it's like god we've failed I mean
the universities really have failed at
that point like if you're afraid to talk
about child rearing because that might
upset a gay person yeah Jesus
I mean what's left at that point it's so
frustrating and it means I feel bad for
the students but I also feel bad for the
parents who are often footing the
tuition Hill because the parents have
faith that if I send my kid to a State
University and I pay tens of thousands
in tuition and they take a course on
topic X like human sexuality that
they're gonna get professors who are
willing to profess to say what they
really think and often are not getting
that so there's a kind of bait and
switch where universities are pretending
to be
these bastions of free speech and
inquiry and and honesty and in fact
everyone's kind of running scared and
these kids are not getting our best
insights they're paying money but we're
not delivering service
how much of an infection not just in the
classroom do you see this as but I think
correctly for mine I think you've
written around 110 published papers is
that right did I get the exact number
right is it a hundred more or less more
or less you lose count at some point I'm
sure you're well aware of the Peter
proposal and Sokol hoax but it's not
just what's happening in the classroom
that's causing the chaos but it actually
may be what's happening before that
related to all of these papers but at
certain disciplines basically have I
don't think I'm overestimating they
almost have no standards yeah at this
point that has got to be just incredibly
frustrating for someone that actually
has published some things legitimately
it's kind of frustrating but I can see
you don't get frustrated easily but like
it doesn't bug me as much as maybe it
bug some other people partly because I
spent a lot of my undergraduate years
taking courses on critical theory and I
read a lot of dairy Don Foucault and
leotard and all those French dudes and
one reason I loved those courses is it
was so easy to get an A by writing out
kind of a [ __ ] paper using the right
terms and using sufficiently obscure
syntax right that so I know that game
that's real very well it's really real
yeah and it's great fun I understand the
appeal of that stuff it's just I can't
imagine spending my adult life doing
nothing but that and that's what's
happening in a lot of the humanities so
it like if if those folks want to do
that and and get paid typically not a
very good salary to do that I don't it
doesn't really visceral offend me the
only danger ISM is when they turn into
activists and they give people like me
grief based on not understanding what I
do yeah well I would imagine a lot of it
just then leaks into your classroom it's
weird it doesn't actually leak in like
when I teach human sexuality right the
kids have a sort of vague
political correctness that they've
absorbed mostly in K through 12 public
school I think but if you actually ask
them have you had any courses on gender
feminism no have you heard of any of
these leading figures from critical
theory or history feminism or even
history of gay rights they know nothing
about
so it's not like they've been
indoctrinated at least not in big state
schools but they've kind of soaked up
some stuff from high school I think that
influences how they interpret everything
so as two guys wearing might I say very
nice shirts right now a shiny purple
shirt and a shiny blue shirt let's talk
about evolutionary aesthetics cool
people don't talk about aesthetics yeah
that much but you think that sort of the
things we're looking at in the West or
maybe not as exciting as they should be
and that there's a problem there is that
fair to say yeah I've been really into
art for a long time and I think art and
beauty are important particularly the
places people live and work and I think
as humans we kind of deserve the best
from artists interior designers stylists
whatever architects that make our lives
as pleasant as possible and I think
basically ever since about 1910 our
architecture has failed mmm has not done
a very good job of delivering visual
environments that are actually humane
and appealing and enjoyable and that
kind of promote mental and physical
health
what happened around 18 modernism man if
you look at the way domestic
architecture worked up until about that
period it was all sort of human scale
and arts and crafts and there are places
you'd want to live where you didn't have
to be educated into a particular elite
notion of what a house should be in
order to appreciate it mm-hmm right and
then you get the Bauhaus international
modernism
white structures crisp hard lines bad
acoustics and suddenly that becomes the
fashion right that becomes what people
think or is the future and nobody likes
it yeah but it's kind of imposed
top-down by the elite you must live like
this like it or not is that top-down
from the elite or is that just that
often those things are just easier to
build probably and cheaper to build or
maybe that the same well the irony is
like you could have taken cheap easy to
build reinforced concrete structures and
built a lot of awesome
cheap houses that were okay or you could
do the traditional route but instead
what you get is every house must be
distinct and must have its own shape and
there can't be any standardization so
the houses end up being expensive and
experimental and hard to maintain and
they leak and everyone's miserable so
they're not really serving the needs of
the the people at large they're just
great for architect egos yeah it's
interesting because I just spent a
couple of months bouncing through a lot
of different countries in Europe and you
know especially on most of these
countries because the history goes back
so far you see incredible architecture
you see even you know I see chairs that
were 150 years old they're like the
woodwork that would go into it and the
craftsmanship and it was like I don't
think we could do this today or if we
could do it today this would have caught
this chair would be in our dollars it
would be like a $6,500 chair we're out
there you know this is what a guy did it
took him a couple days and he could sell
it and earn a wage and it's like we've
just the economics of everything have
gotten out of whack yeah and like nice
table here on this flat probably the new
third slide did on the table right you
walked in so I know you mean it yeah
I've made a few pieces for an attorney
my day and that that's pretty cool but
yeah it was the visual art in particular
the economics mean like abstract
painting just is so much faster to do
than map
isn't a tional painting right if you're
a young aspiring artist and you want a
career and you want to give your gallery
a certain flow of work that they can
sell it's a lot harder to do that if
you're doing representational paintings
that take a hundred three hundred hours
then an abstract work that takes a tenth
of that so the economic pressures are
also in that direction yeah but people
have kind of voted with their feet and
like that they don't like elite abstract
art they don't like conceptual art but
it is like the word the right were there
or they just don't they just don't know
where its conditioning or it's that we
all like to like what everybody else
likes sort of thing I think everybody
knows that they're kind of supposed to
enjoy going to like well we're visiting
this city we should go to the
Contemporary Art Museum and they get
there and there's a bunch of terrible
video art and there's a bunch of very
puzzling conceptual art and they read
the little descriptions on the walls and
they go it just makes no sense because
it's written by an art curator for other
art curators mm-hmm and it's all
completely alienating and that's that's
sad because it means they're being told
this is the highest expression of your
culture but it's completely inaccessible
to you so what what do you look at that
gives me some excitement or can still
sort of renew your spirit let's say well
there there is a movement of kind of
neo-traditional ism and in art where
there's there's certain places like New
York Academy of Arts that are actually
teaching students how to draw and paint
and sculpt and and do the sort of
traditional skills that people associate
with art it's just a little hard to get
a foothold in the like the New York or
London gallery system if that's the kind
of work that you do but my hope is that
like the Bay Area billionaires will
start collect
that stuff mm-hmm I think the Chinese
art market is has got a real thirst for
good representational art mm-hm and I
think that's gonna start to dominate the
art world pretty soon so what's the
evolutionary need for a good art I mean
what's the psychological I mean I know
you're okay there's an expression of
something that can't quite be said but
what's like the driving force behind
that so yeah on the one hand there's why
do we bother to make art on the other
hand why why do we like certain kinds of
art and there's been a lot more research
on why do we like certain kinds of
patterns and colors and forms and
compositions and whatever but there's no
sort of unified theory of aesthetics in
fact I would say there's more good stuff
published on that topic between about
1870 in 1920 then since because that's
when people were sort of very inspired
by Darwin evolutionary aesthetics was a
field there were dozens of books
published on it and then modernism came
and everyone forgot all that how could
this be connected to the earlier topic
which is sexuality so for example my gay
male friends generally speaking have a
much better eye for art or for style or
for fashion yeah you know you could get
away in that crew you know you mean like
you got a nice kid on you got a nice
shirt like that's you know do you like I
mean that's a compliment like where Jen
I get just broadly speaking it's like my
straight guy friends all kind of wear
big shirts and they don't know exactly
how to do their hair and they're you
know so there's a connection between
sexuality and artistic vision I think
that's absolutely true and it's not what
you would predict from first principles
it's really weird if you look around at
other species the males are typically
much more ornamented than the females
they have the the amazing plumage and
they do the incredible songs and dances
and the females are usually kind of drab
and
not that aesthetic the power birds that
make these incredible kind of
installation works that's all the males
then you get two humans or at least
American males American straight males
and it's like can't you even find
clothes that fit
I would like colors is the big jerk and
like what is up with your house you know
and when I did Leon by Jordan Peters and
so two of the copies to tell people in
their room yeah so I have no idea why
gay men have better taste in straight
men I think that's a fascinating sure
there has to be something going on there
but I think men can level up obviously
because like British and European men
aren't as hopeless if you grow up a
young man in Italy you kind of absorb
some ideas about style and even the
British kind of aristocrats landed
gentry class have a certain look that
it's a bit traditionalist but at least
there's taste I don't know if this is
gonna quite make sense but we'll be
almost getting there say ten years ago
with the rise of the metrosexual yeah
man it sort of crashed because I guess
maybe it relates back to what he said
the beginning about where we are more
Puritan so where there was this idea
there was just like mocking of them like
yeah they're just gay but don't admit it
or something like that and that whole
thing seemed to crash like there was
this little brief window where straight
guys were like dressing better or yeah I
had cooler haircuts or something
something there well even five years ago
when I lived in New York for a little
bit and uh hung on hung out a lot in
Brooklyn there was sort of that was peak
hipster in in Brooklyn and the guys
there the straight guys put a lot of
effort into grooming and haircuts an
authentic style and this or that is in
fashion and I thought this is really
cool this is like a Europeanisation of
male taste and culture but it was also
very masculine mhm it wasn't sort of
like late 70s disco culture or early 90s
Ray
of culture or Burning Man culture you
sort of more old-school masculine this
way that's cool like I want to go to a
proper barber and get a proper haircut
and like it's all flannel and boots and
whatever and I love that stuff but I
think it kind of had its moment and
evaporated on a no I think they just
priced themselves out of the market
right yeah yeah yeah or they just got
all too busy on Twitter yeah well that
it always comes back to that let's talk
a little bit about me
selection regardless of your sexuality
there seems to be this new thing right
now where if you're not open to dating
absolutely anyone under many
circumstances no matter how they look or
how they take care of themselves or
whether they brush their teeth or
whether they have a penis order of
Aegina or any combination of anything
but if you are just open to anything
there's a pretty loud and growing voice
out there that is trying to frame
everyone as a kid yeah just the reverse
of what choosing a mate really has been
about it's insane I mean for 500 all
right I got you I got emotional Miller
there we're 500 million years right our
vertebrate ancestors have been choosing
their mates selectively because that is
the highest stakes decision any organism
makes is who do I recombine my genes
with right and so all the way through
the chordates and the vertebrates and
the mammals and the primates you get
particularly females being choosy about
you know who they breed with who sires
their kids but then as soon as humans
start doing pair bonds million to
million years ago and the males start
investing more in offspring start
forming longer term relationships then
we also have incentives to be choosy
about our female mates and so this is
the one domain where if you have even a
shred of libertarian in you or you
respect freedom of association at all or
you think it's okay to care who you
spend your life with and
what kind of children you you create
then mate choice should be a kind of
domain of freedom right like this is a
good place to be prejudiced so to speak
right yeah like you should have some
discriminating yeah have judgment on
imitating taste and you can always be
open to the idea that maybe the current
set of criteria that I have maybe could
be nudged or improved or tweaked or
maybe I'm subject to certain stereotypes
and maybe I could overcome those true of
course people tend to get better at me
choice in their 30s than in their teens
but for someone to start lecturing you
politically like you shouldn't be
attracted to women you should be
attracted to anybody or any any kind of
being or in what any species any age
like no let please let me be attracted
to who I'm attracted to because that
should be like the the pinnacle of human
freedom yeah if you don't believe in
freedom anywhere else you should believe
in me choice freedom it should be a
fundamental human right I think and
where you get a horrible totalitarian
societies really infringing on my choice
freedom like you're not allowed to marry
that person or you know you have to do
an arranged marriage to that person we
kind of recoil at that I think of that's
horrible and yet in America we have busy
bodies and virtue signalers telling us
your mate choice criteria are too narrow
so where to gay people fit in all of
this then at a biological or an
evolutionary perspective you've brought
up the point of passing on genes mankind
gay couples or gay people whether you're
a couple or not don't do that
and he's biologically speaking so what
what do you make of that condition is
that even the right word now I'm gonna
get I'm gonna get us both in trouble
probably
just for me asking the question let's
call it a trait trait traits pretty
neutral okay all right traits pretty
neutral well here's a fascinating thing
about homosexuality is people have been
developing or trying to develop theories
of male homosexuality and it's kind of
evolutionary origins and functions for
30 40 years and there is no good theory
of it yet it's a complete mystery I've
never seen any compelling explanation of
male on sexuality so what would be a
compelling a compelling argument would
be okay there's costs of being like
exclusively attracted to your own sex
and therefore not typically having as
many kids but there's some
countervailing benefits of some sort may
be benefits to your extended family or
benefits to your group or something else
but nobody can make the math work mmm
enough to kind of explain that female
bisexuality is much easier right
you can go well as long as a woman is
sometimes attracted to men enough to
have kids then also being attracted to
women it might be no cost at all or it
might even be a benefit in terms of
social networking and making friends sex
is a great way to make friends if a lot
more males were bisexual that would be
equally easy to explain it's the
exclusive homosexuality that's very hard
to explain it certainly exists it exists
at a you know a percentage that's much
much higher than you can explain it's
just well it's just mutations or it's
just maladaptive I think that won't work
so this is where I'll be kind of
epistemic ly humble and say man I have
no idea huh it's an it's a fascinating
problem maybe somebody will crack it
within 10 or 20 years right it's
interesting because if you were coming
at it from another perspective like a
religious perspective Wednesday you
would find that to be a moral quandary
that then you could extrapolate that all
sorts of different judgments on yeah but
I can see the way you answer it
it's like just is the thing yeah maybe
we'll get more data on it mm but it is
but what do you make of the fact that
there are seemingly many more bisexual
women where I don't know any gay couple
that one of the guys is sneaking out at
night to bangles I've never heard of
that but you have heard of obviously
straight couples where the guy is you
know on the DL or whatever yeah yeah
well my girlfriend Diana Fleischman has
a whole theory of female bisexuality
that's that's to do with the social
networking benefits but then the
question is yeah why don't the men do
that too just like if you're a guy and
you kind of swing both ways then like
doing gay sex can be a great way to make
male friends also and it's well now I
know we have our promo for the show and
so in a way the quandary isn't why do
any male homosexuals exist the quandary
is why aren't all males and females
bisexual mm-hmm and do you think some of
that yours from now we might look back
and go wow that's just societal pressure
it might be I think certainly there's a
huge amount of stigma against male
bisexuals from both sexes um but
especially women female bisexuality used
to be stigmatized maybe 30 years ago and
not so much anymore
yeah so it that could change what are
some of the other topics that are that
are really on your mind these days let's
hit up effective altruism yeah let's
talk about that I don't know if you've
had many guests on talking about the
fact of altruism but it's not in tonight
actually it's sort of my hot topic of
the last few years so it's a social
movement a moral movement it's some of
the smartest young people I've ever met
and their basic goal in life is do the
most good they can based on reason and
evidence rather than sentimentality and
virtue signaling I've done a little bit
of this sort of in an ancillary way with
some of the libertarians yeah yeah and
so the kind of major domains they tend
to focus on
are things like how do we get charities
to be more effective at reducing global
poverty or promoting global public
health how do we overcome factory
farming and be nice to animals and
promote animal welfare and so a lot of
the effective altruists are vegan for
ethical reasons and then a lot of them
are focused on just survival of the
species how do we reduce existential
risks to humanity like nuclear war
bioweapons and artificial intelligence
risks so maybe the most distinctive
thing they have is this kind of ultra
long term perspective that's like we are
just these transient little beings the
thing that really matters is what does
humanity turn into how long do we last
do we colonize the universe or do we
fail and folks who think most seriously
about that think it's actually that
lasting minimizing existential risk that
is absolutely crucial and everything
else is just kind of fluff and [ __ ]
so this weird like the transhumanist who
would sort of fit with it is there or so
I love this stuff because I'm a sci-fi
guy I mean I mentioned Phil okay dick
before I mean every one of his stories
or books are about the inevitability of
all of these things is there a risk
though I'm always looking at what's
beyond the horizon instead of going on
right now I don't really think there's a
risk unless like the vast majority of
humans became effective altruists
there's already so many people who are
obsessed with you know diversity and
equity and inclusion and economic growth
and all the ordinary problems that
politicians talk about like that's
covered this already a lot of smart
people working on that the the big
neglected topics tend to be the kind of
science fictiony topics where you need a
sort of cadre of genius aspies right to
work on it when nobody else is taking
its
really yeah well speaking of aspies
that's that's interesting what if we
wanted to get into a little a little
controversial as well what what is that
all about that so many of the creators
now or the people that are coming out of
the tech world even though you can
obviously make plenty of arguments that
the 10 world is now in a sort of
implosion and certainly not the creative
place it was say 10 years ago but that
so much creativity came out of a world
that had so many people that were
seemingly uncreated mm-hmm I think it's
fascinating um I sort of identify as
moderately Aspie myself kind of
high-functioning Asperger's and I've
written some stuff about how neuro
diversity issues like being asked be
kind of rub up against free speech
issues because like a newsman that other
people who are ask me don't always do a
good job of understanding the beliefs
and desires of other people and
particularly what they might find
offensive right so they might just say
something so they might just say [ __ ]
and then beasts really surprised that it
was distressing to someone and so if you
have a model of speech that says you
must never cause offence that assumes
you can anticipate what will cause
offense and a lot of people can't
anticipate that because their brains
don't work that way so you either need
to say okay aspies you can never say
anything or cut them some slack and say
we understand you'll offend people once
in a while but that's okay because
that's you just that's part of your deal
man I've never thought about this but is
this somehow explain what's going on in
value right now you have a bunch of
people who are somewhat socially awkward
let's say now created incredible
technology that allowed us to all
connect
but then when voices that are exposed
that's a hard way frame you and voices
that are a little out there or a little
contrarian or whatever that might have
who does actually get out there the only
way they can deal with it is to shut
that voice off or something like that
like we have why we're seeing so much D
platforming and
right they have to be overly
systematizing about it they have to be
like oh man I can't I can't navigate
these gray areas if I'm running a social
media platform or patreon or whatever
right so I'm gonna just have a hard and
fast rule that says if I get enough
complaints i die' platform that person
or i don't know the difference between
porn and erotica and just slightly sexy
art so I'm going to say no nipples or
whatever that's a kind of a spirit again
blowback from people where you like you
don't really know why they're upset so
in a weird way if you have a bunch of
the creators of Silicon Valley then are
coming from that world and then you
suddenly bring in a bunch of executives
that come from the social justice world
mm-hmm that really shows like that's a
match made in hell rights just matter
antimatter yeah it's it's terrible and
what I hoped would happen is that maybe
five or ten years ago it seemed like aha
like tech is dominating culture
generally and tech is dominated by
aspies so hopefully ass be values of
being kind of tolerant and eccentric and
nerdy and like getting weird little
enthusiasms that that would kind of
trickle down and create a more tolerant
culture is that what you would have
predicted say ten years ago yeah really
and instead you have the opposite you
have the social justice activists taking
over and basically saying all of that
quirky freedom that you you ask me
people value we're gonna legislate that
away you you can't have that that's it's
tragic
hope the pendulum swing swings back but
as long as the leaders of the social
media platforms don't have the guts to
say look this is our people outspoken
eccentric slightly socially oblivious
people and that's okay and the rest of
you just have to kind of suck it up and
deal with it that's what they should be
doing yeah it's interesting I'm at the
point with all this and you know how you
tube and Twitter patreon and the whole
thing I'm really at the point of this
where I actually believe that that
solution is gone and I don't think it
can come from the top anymore
I really don't believe that I think that
thing has become so close that I would
say the only way it can come is now from
the bottom and then the people will
basically rise up against these things
and I know that's like it's sort of pie
in the sky because what does that even
mean do we all sign off on the same day
do we all but you know whatever that
means but I almost see that as the only
way to do this because they've had we've
done everything else or the government
will get involved and that certainly
rings all the bells that I'm not happy
with on my libertarian side yeah I I
think at least in terms of universities
the only solution to some of the
university problems is the government
actually saying at least the public
universities that are in principle bound
by the Constitution you guys have to
obey the First Amendment yeah or you
lose federal funding I think that's the
only leverage yeah and I was really kind
of hoping the POTUS would do that at
some point in the last year or two I'm
pretty disappointed that he hasn't
mm-hmm wasn't a weird way he almost
benefits the more that they go against
their right now because that feeds his
base of yeah aggrieved and politically
correct yeah you know that they see
political correctness running amuck yeah
something like that
all right before we finish up give me
give me one thing we're at the beginning
of 2019 right now give me one thing that
we should be sort of thinking about that
we're not making about right now I love
the thought experiment of like once Elon
Musk succeeds and we start colonizing
Mars what what are the relationships and
social structures in the Mars colony is
going
look like I'm fascinated by this this
issue like yeah artal are the colony is
going to be like communist utopias are
they going to be libertarian
aspirational states are they is everyone
gonna do monogamous lifelong marriage is
it going to be crazy polyamorous kinky
stuff I think it's great to think about
this stuff before we attempt it and I
think Mars is going to be this amazing
experiment or like this colony gets
formed based on these social and sexual
assumptions and this one gets formed and
this one fails catastrophic ly or or it
like it doesn't work well enough and it
just borrows the organization of this
other place so I think it'll be this
incredible kind of behavioral science
laboratory and I can't where I say
that's not too far from the way America
was set up right that's exactly those to
be those places of experiment yeah it's
yeah it's the way the East Coast was two
hundred two hundred fifty years ago and
I think the difference now is the
colonies will be able to communicate
with each other and with us and be able
to measure a bunch of outcomes and
deliberately experiment and I think we
need to kind of get out ahead of that
and start like rereading all of our
classic science fiction and figuring out
how is this going to apply for reals now
now that we do it yeah which is so
related to why you think art is
important because fiction is just as
important I mean you realize it all ends
with that eventually they figure it out
they have their Tea Party and then we
blow them up right yeah but they do
beautiful Art Nouveau like domes in the
meanwhile yeah Jeffrey I'm so glad we
finally did this yeah let's do it again
for sure and if you want to see a good
combination of bright smart thought and
snark on Twitter follow Jeffrey at
primal Polly
[Music]